[MUSIC PLAYING]
QUENTIN HARDY: Thank
you very much for that.
I'm going to keep my
introduction very quick, not
simply because I'm
about to introduce
two very well-known people who
have brought us the future,
but for another reason
I'll get into at the end
of my introduction.
Now, this morning what
we looked at really
was a picture of a world
of enterprise computing,
in which the cloud is not
simply a distant data center.
The cloud is an
awareness of mobility.
It's a computational world,
in which there is mobile,
there are APIs creating and
disassembling and building
new software systems
at all times,
there's AI mediating and, of
course in the cloud itself,
in those data centers, there
are enormous databases and AI
systems and machine-learning
systems that
are an almost continual two-way
interaction with mobility,
with endpoint
devices, with sensors,
and these are just
the early days
of what amounts to a kind of
computational intelligence
distributed at every
point in the planet.
So, I mentioned this to
Vint Cerf the other day,
I sort of said this is a picture
of the world we are occupying
and it will increase
in proficiency.
And he said, oh well that's
ubiquitious computing
and Mark Weiser was talking
about that in the '70s.
And Vint knows that because,
of course, he architected
the internet, he did
TCP/IP, and since 2005 he's
been the chief
evangelist at Google,
where he is involved in spotting
the best internet technologies
and fostering the
idea those products
and those services can be
best built in the largest
possible systems.
Marc Andreessen, of course,
developed the Mosaic web
browser, he co-founded
Netscape, he
started a web hosting
company called Loudcloud back
in the day where companies
could just plug into computing
like it was a utility.
And now, of course, at
Andreessen Horowitz,
he invests exactly in this world
of computational intelligence
everywhere.
Now until recently
of course, Marc
was off Twitter having
had a minor career
as the ultimate tweet stormer.
He came back
recently onto Twitter
leveraging a site called 21.co,
where he answers questions
for $100 a pop and
the proceeds of that
go to the organization,
Black Girls Code.
We love this idea.
So, we decided at
the session today,
every time Mark
answers a question
we're going to contribute
$100 to Black Girls Code.
And, of course, in the
interest of fairness,
Vint's answers get $100 too.
So, without further ado, Mark
Andreessen and Vint Cerf.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
QUENTIN HARDY: So, let's start.
The cloud.
That's going to be a
big deal, yes or no?
MARC ANDREESSEN: Yes.
VINT CERF: Sorry, what?
QUENTIN HARDY: That's $200.
Keep count.
That's $200.
VINT CERF: But, I
want $200 for that.
QUENTIN HARDY: Oh.
OK.
Yeah well, develop
it in the next one.
So, we talked about this idea
of computational intelligence
everywhere in this enormous
mediating influence.
What do you think will be the
most important barely discerned
or unrealized
dimensions of this,
particularly where
enterprise is concerned?
VINT CERF: So, my
first thought is
that we're moving from a
space where the cloud is
kind of homogeneous
and uniform to a space
where it can be and is
becoming less uniform.
It's becoming differentiated
and so, the cloud's providers
may be able to offer a variety
of different kinds of services.
At Google, for example,
we're seriously
looking at quantum computing.
We're seriously looking
at neural networks.
We're trying to make
those various capabilities
accessible through
publicly known APIs.
The whole idea here
is to give a variety
of functional
computational capabilities
in the cloud systems.
But, there's a
second possibility
that I'm curious
about and that's
the recognition that there
are multiple clouds out there
and there is a conceivable
utility in being
able to move data back and
forth among the clouds.
Even imagining
doing computations
partly in one cloud
and partly in another
and exchanging information
back and forth.
QUENTIN HARDY: How
many big clouds
do you think there'll be?
VINT CERF: It's hard to say.
One thing that can
happen is that companies
will want to run little
cloudlets of their own.
They want to be able to
interact with the major clouds.
For example, keeping some data
on there and the protocols
for doing this however
are not quite there.
It's like the days
of the internet.
Before the internet, we had
networks from IBM and Digital
and Hewlett-Packard
you could connect
their brands of computers
together over the networks,
but you couldn't link
them across brands.
And so, the internet
said wait a minute,
let's see if we can
find a way to do that.
So, that's where I think
Intercloud may eventually
emerge but Marc you may
have a different view.
MARC ANDREESSEN: Let me come at
it from a different standpoint.
You're talking about the idea
basically of intelligence
permeating everything and
then being connected up
to the cloud.
I'd just come at it from a
different or maybe a more
elliptical angle, I think this
is something environmentalists
should be very fired up about.
I'm kind of surprised
they're not,
which is leverage on
the real world, leverage
on physical resources.
Let me give you just the
obvious example people
are playing with right now.
The average car in
the United States
is utilized 4% of the time.
So, 96% of the time it
sits parked, by the way
there are 1,000,000,000
parking spots in the US,
and if you aggregate up those
1,000,000,000 parking spots,
you have the state
of Connecticut
literally, in terms of size.
This is just massive
waste and inefficiency
because the cars aren't
in the cloud and so,
96% of the time they sit there.
Then by definition, 96% of
the sheet metal and the glass
and everything else that goes
into the car that's produced
is just sitting idle.
Take on the other hand
the new world emerging
of self-driving cars
connected to the cloud
and then run as a cloud-mediated
network with rides on demand,
and you probably can't get
a car utilization up to 100%
but you could probably get
it up to 50%, 60%, 70%, 80%.
QUENTIN HARDY: Step functions
[INAUDIBLE] efficiency.
MARC ANDREESSEN: 10X
increased in efficiency
and therefore a
corresponding decrease
in the number of automobiles,
therefore decreasing
physical impact--
QUENTIN HARDY: And
in the creation--
MARC ANDREESSEN:
--of production.
QUENTIN HARDY: In the creation
of that efficiency, in itself,
there are opportunities.
Other things are freed up.
MARC ANDREESSEN:
From an economic--
QUENTIN HARDY: As someone
who grew up in Connecticut,
equating it to a large disused
parking lot is interesting.
MARC ANDREESSEN: Exactly.
I'll let you speculate on that.
It also means you
can transform cities.
You can turn cities into
parks because you can take out
a lot of the streets and
a lot of the parking lots
but just the physical
impact of the resource load
on the environment.
There are going to be
all kinds of areas,
whereas the world
gets smarter and we
can capture more
data and software,
bring it up on the cloud, and
then lever the physical world
through software.
There's huge efficiency
gains that people aren't even
thinking about today
that I think also
will go straight to a lot of the
current environmental issues.
QUENTIN HARDY: Vint, I want to
dig a little bit--, sorry go
ahead.
VINT CERF: This sounds
a lot like trying
to model what's
going on and more
accurately, in
Singapore they are
building a model of the city.
It's a city state.
There are about what, 5,000,000
people who live there,
but they're building
a very accurate model
to try to understand how
the resources of the city
are used by the
people who live there.
You guys remember the matrix?
And no, I don't think I was
the model for the architect,
but anyway.
[LAUGHTER]
QUENTIN HARDY: You've been
programmed to think that.
VINT CERF: But, the important
thing is that in the story,
they were emulating the
population of people
in order to feed them ads
to see how they would react.
But, what the
Singaporean researchers
are doing is trying to do a
very, very fine-grained model
of the way in which
transportation
and other resources in
the city are being used
in order to understand
if they changed things,
if they could modify it,
it would make a difference.
So, this modeling
thing and ability
to calculate based
on data you received
is a really powerful idea.
QUENTIN HARDY: So
they're going to model
for an unintended consequence?
VINT CERF: Well,
that's possible.
QUENTIN HARDY:
Yeah, that's great.
I wanted to dig a
little bit deeper
into what you were saying about
different types of computing
in the cloud, could
be CPUs and GPUs, that
exists now, neural nets
and quantum, eventually,
Google's doing research, this
is something that you entirely
foresee at this point.
What are the use cases?
What sort of world
does that build?
VINT CERF: Well, think
about the kinds of problems
that these various computing
engines are capable of solving.
The neural networks are
not the sort of thing
you do for payroll, for
example, but yet it's
a very powerful tool for
machine learning for typical AI
kinds of applications.
In the case of pun
computing, there
are certain algorithms
that will allow
you to complete a computation
much, much faster than you
would with conventional methods.
On the other hand, some problems
running on a quantum computer
take longer, or
at least no better
than a conventional machine.
The whole idea here
is to get the problem
to fit the computational
capability.
Now we have this broader
range of opportunities
to match the computing
capability with the problem
that we're faced with.
And that, I think, is unexplored
territory at this point.
QUENTIN HARDY: It's
really going to change
the educational system on how
coding is taught too, isn't it?
VINT CERF: Well, I
don't know whether it
will change the
educational system itself,
but it might certainly
force the educational system
to help people learn
how to compute using
these different kinds of tools.
QUENTIN HARDY: Think
about use cases a lot.
You could even end up in a
regulated computing environment
because quantum could be used
to damage a cryptocurrency
near and dear to your heart and
as much as you can perhaps, hit
the encryption of Bitcoin
using a quantum formula.
VINT CERF: OK but Marc
would probably agree,
this is ping pong, right?
At this stage of
the game, it's well
known that certain
kinds of crypto
are going to be made less secure
because of certain quantum
algorithms.
Shor's algorithm,
for example, that
gets in the way of doing
logarithm like algorithm.
The solution to that is
different mathematics
and already people are
exploring the whole new range
of mathematics that
will not break against,
at least Shor's algorithm
wouldn't break it.
I don't know maybe you
are looking into that.
MARC ANDREESSEN: When you
tell a venture capitalist
there's a giant
technical problem,
we just get all excited.
QUENTIN HARDY: Find
me a smart guy.
MARC ANDREESSEN: Find me
a smart guy to go solve it
and we'll fund it.
There is new math
underway now and there
will be new ways to do that.
QUENTIN HARDY: OK.
MARC ANDREESSEN: But, it
might be a major change.
This might be significant
and, by the way,
it might be the world
needs a step function
increase in security.
QUENTIN HARDY: Yeah.
That would be a good
thing right now.
MARC ANDREESSEN: For
example, this week, perhaps.
QUENTIN HARDY: Depends on how
you feel about your democracy.
Now, you were
saying to me earlier
that you are seeing
a lot more, I
hate saying conventional,
but historic businesses,
non-Valley businesses moving in
and taking a really active role
in learning about
the cloud directly.
CEO straight to the
problem, learning about ML,
how do they approach
it differently.
What do they want from this?
MARC ANDREESSEN: I think
there's a history of it.
A lot of big companies
got excited in the 1990s
because the internet
had arrived and IBM had
e-business and the whole thing.
Then, a lot of big companies
in 2000, 2001, 2002
breathed a massive
sigh of relief
and said oh thank god that
internet thing didn't work.
Stick a fork in it, it's done.
Everybody knows the dotcom thing
was a bubble that was a joke,
it's over and now we don't
have to worry about it.
They maintained that view until,
I would say, about 2010, 2011.
Then, I think it flipped pretty
much directly into panic.
It's interesting
it also coincides
with the generational
change of leadership
at a lot of the big
companies where they now
have a younger generation
of leaders actually running
the companies, who
grew up with computers,
unlike the previous generation.
In the last six years, we've
seen a significant move
and, more recently, a
flood of big companies
from incumbent industries
coming to Silicon Valley
and trying to learn what
all this stuff means
and trying to figure
out how to use
it to either improve
their business
or defend against new attackers.
QUENTIN HARDY: Are they
looking at--, sorry go ahead.
MARC ANDREESSEN:
Correspondingly, we've
also seen the rise of entire new
generations of startups, that
are now using these
new technologies,
to directly go after incumbent
industries that historically
have never been
threatened by technology
and never been threatened
by technology startups.
QUENTIN HARDY: An
Airbnb essentially
models a hotel chain or an
Uber models a taxi fleet.
MARC ANDREESSEN: The
basic calculus here
is that the tech
industry historically
has been very good at having
a big impact on industries
in which there is
rapid technology
change, rapid productivity
change, that also turn out
to be industries
that 1, just aren't
that big relative to the
size of the economy and 2,
aren't that regulated.
Media and entertainment,
consumer electronics,
retail, there's just not
that big as a percentage
of the economy right.
Most of the economy is
health care, education,
and construction, government.
These giant industries that
are just big and gigantic
and regulated and with
huge income and strength.
It appears, or at least
what a lot of entrepreneurs
in the Valley believe, is that
the new technologies are now
so powerful and so potent, if
you bring mobile, plus network
access, plus AI, plus
whatever, and you apply it
into an industry like real
estate or transportation
or education or health
care, you can now
actually have a big impact.
It wasn't possible
in the past and so
we're seeing the attackers
also shop at the same time.
VINT CERF: I'm
actually going to argue
that big is not necessarily
the only reason the cloud is
of interest.
The other reason is
continuous computation,
continuous gathering of
data, continuous observation
and analysis can make
a huge difference
in the medical world.
For example, you only go to see
the doctor when you're sick,
so the doctors model of
you is you're always sick
and he never sees you
when you're healthy.
If you're monitoring
your body for example,
then you can get a baseline
that says this is what's normal.
Now they have the
ability to say,
uh oh something is not normal.
But it only works because you
have this continuous monitoring
going on.
That's probably also true
for various kinds of business
where you're trying
to understand what's
going on dynamically and being
able to see things in real time
makes a huge difference.
We don't have time for it
in some of our advertising
mechanisms.
We know in real time
how much people are
spending on a particular ad.
We can stop showing
an ad when it runs out
of the limit that
the users have set
but that only works
if you have real time
computation of billing.
QUENTIN HARDY: I think
just to circle back,
it's interesting to look at this
process of these new companies
modeling an industry
and then attacking it
because when they
do this, they don't
look at it to talk about how
different types of computing
are.
They don't look at the
toolset in a siloed way
if you look at a [INAUDIBLE]
or an Airbnb or a Snap,
there's mobility, there's
AI, there's all these things
and they're not thinking
about them in a siloed way,
they're thinking about
a very continuous way
with the objective
of using the best
capability towards their end.
MARC ANDREESSEN: And
they're not trying
to defend legacy,
investment, status quo.
Business models are
now trying to find
big employee bases
that maybe do need
to fundamentally transform.
It's asymmetric.
The odds of success
of the attacker
are lower than the odds of the
defender defending successfully
but the challenge is
easier, attacking is easier.
QUENTIN HARDY: And even
from a risk point of view,
if you learn something, you've
got an asset at the end of it
anyway.
MARC ANDREESSEN: Yeah, right.
VINT CERF: You mentioned
business models
and this raises an
interesting problem.
Some companies build
their businesses
around the model, which
has been very successful.
Newspapers here are an
example, and then the world
moves out from under them.
One interesting
question is whether we
can use these computational
models to sort of help you A)
figure out whether not your
business model is failing,
or B) what alternative
business models could there be.
The idea of being able to do
what-if simulations of a fairly
large scale model
of what's going on,
could be a very
powerful tool and only
a cloud computing environment
has the capacity to do that.
MARC ANDREESSEN: I'll
give you an example.
My friend Sam Larson has
this theory, basically
says historically in the economy
it felt like bits have always
moved faster than atoms but in
reality for most, the economy
atoms move faster than bits.
Why do chain fast food
restaurants exist?
It's because if you're a hungry
traveler at 9 o'clock at night
and see McDonald's sign,
you know what's there.
And if you just see
random Joe's diner,
you don't know if it's any
good or not, therefore,
this massive rise of
chains across the economy
and this massive decline
of independent restaurants
and bars and everything else.
What he says basically is, that
was just because it's actually
easier to get the atoms in place
in the form of the McDonald's
sign than it was to transmit
the information about which
local restaurants are good.
In the new world, it flips.
It's now easier to go on
Yelp or TripAdvisor, or any
of these sites, or Airbnb
and be able to discover it.
No, I actually want to
stay in this apartment,
I want to go to this
local restaurant,
I want to go to this local
bar, this local coffee shop
but I'm going to have
actually a better experience.
QUENTIN HARDY: It's
changing the consumer, too,
because they can sharpen
their desires better.
It's not just the
generic McDonald's,
it's an interesting
experience they can derive.
MARC ANDREESSEN: That's right.
And then you get the feedback.
you collect the data and
so you get the data back.
You get the two-way ratings
on Uber and Airbnb and eBay
and you get the two-way
ratings, so, you actually have,
if anything, better
quality control
than the centralized management.
VINT CERF: This raises a
very interesting question
about the accuracy and
quality of the data
and in some cases, the
integrity of the data.
Somebody who wants to
mess up your business
could conceivably go in
and monkey with the data,
giving you the wrong
impression of how
your business is running.
So, I think that
there are gotchas
that hide in this infrastructure
that we're going to have
to work hard to protect.
QUENTIN HARDY: Who
knew in the new world
it's still going to be
hard to be good, right?
The humans.
To speak to the data problem
and the large incumbent problem,
the big incumbents
come and obviously they
have enormous amount of
data they want to use,
and they want to
generate new data,
and understand their
customers better,
what is the decisive
thing for a company?
Is it going to be the amount
of data, the quality of data,
the reliability of data,
or is it case by case?
VINT CERF: My first reaction
is that all three have a role
to play here and
I would not want
to elevate one after the
other although, the quality
of the data and
it's reliability is
terribly important
because otherwise it's
garbage in, garbage out.
But, I mentioned
earlier this notion
of being able to capture
things on a continuous basis.
That turns out to be
almost as important as all
the other parameters
that you mentioned
because that continuity gives
you a sense for what's going on
in a way that you
wouldn't normally
get if you have a rather slow
collection of information.
MARC ANDREESSEN: I
would take speed.
I think it's simply
speed of adaptation
because just look at the ways
you deal with data today.
They're just completely
different than they
were five years ago.
The ability, for example, to
apply deep learning to data
is a brand new thing
and you indicated,
the young companies
that are growing
up with this technology are
just doing it by default.
The older companies that have
built up data sets and methods
of processing data
over 30 or 40 years
aren't moving that fast on it.
I think the algorithmic
improvements and the ability
to leverage the cloud and all
of the things that are happening
and just the huge new flood
of data that's arriving,
I think it's going to be a
question of flexibility to be
how fast can your technical
workforce actually adapt
and actually do things
in a better way.
VINT CERF: Now we need to
arm wrestle a little bit
because think about rapid
training on the stock market.
One of the problems with
a lot of those algorithms
is they all follow the same
thing like kids playing soccer.
The ball is over here if
the market's going down,
they all sell.
If the market is
going up, the all buy.
And the market goes like that,
you have a bang-bang control
algorithm so, you have
to be careful about fast
leading to instability.
My question to you,
Marc, is how do you
balance the stability question
against the speed of response?
MARC ANDREESSEN: We assume
that you're taking care of it.
[LAUGHTER]
QUENTIN HARDY: Well that's OK.
VINT CERF: OK.
MARC ANDREESSEN: So
it is interesting--
QUENTIN HARDY: Done.
VINT CERF: Right.
MARC ANDREESSEN: I mean
most of our companies
are so small when they
start that they don't have
that much of an impact at all.
And so, the goal is
to get into a position
where they actually
have an impact.
VINT CERF: Is this a good
problem to have, you're saying?
MARC ANDREESSEN: Yeah it's
a high quality problem
to have once you get in position
where you start to introduce
that level of instability.
For the most part, our
company's self-identity
as they're up against the man.
If it screwed up it's
because the man has already
screwed it up.
Now whether they're right
or fooling themselves we--
VINT CERF: We can hope
that everybody who
comes and uses Google
Cloud Service will
have that problem, because it
will be big enough to do that.
That would be good
for everyone of you.
MARC ANDREESSEN:
That would be good.
VINT CERF: OK.
QUENTIN HARDY: This is
very much an "if" question
because I know you
love your job and I
know you see 100 companies
but if each of you
were to start a company
now in this world,
what would you go after, what
would be an interesting thing
to build around?
VINT CERF: I know
what I would do.
I've fallen in love with
a book on microbiology
by Bruce Alvarez
and his colleagues.
It's in the sixth edition.
It's 1,766 pages of
beautiful illustrations
and explanation about what
goes on inside a cell.
It's Manhattan in
there, it's not
a bag full of water with
chemicals rolling around.
If I were to start
all over again,
I would want to dive
into understanding what's
going on in there
and then extract
the knowledge, which we are
gaining over time, in order
to do useful things.
Our Calico company has
noticed that people get old
and they're trying to
stop that of course,
the engineers have a solution.
You know that's not the solution
[INAUDIBLE] have and at my age,
we care a lot about that.
So understanding
what's going on will
yield a lot of insights
potential therapies
and other things that
I'd be fascinated--
and besides the whole
thing is so interesting,
it's unbelievably complicated.
There's even a store and
forward packet switching system
inside there, moving
proteins around that
have little labels
on them to say
where they're supposed to go
QUENTIN HARDY: Really?
VINT CERF: And other
little proteins that
crawl along the miton tubules.
They get grown and there's
Pac-Man on this side
and they carry the label
proteins to the place
where they're supposed to go.
The problem is
mother nature figured
out packet switching
3,500,000,000 years ago,
it just has a while to catch up.
QUENTIN HARDY: --you
can do this thing.
And you?
MARC ANDREESSEN: I think
there is something happening.
Building on what
Vint said, I think
there's something
happening in science
that's the one layer below
what we've been talking about.
We've been talking about the
impact of computing and cloud
on technology and business.
There is a layer below what's
happening in science which
is what we see everyday now,
which is, we see world class
biologists coming out of great
research universities who are
also top-end computer scientists
and 10 years ago that wasn't
the case and all
of a sudden it is.
It's a generational change.
We're seeing top-end physicists
who are software experts,
we're seeing top
end economists who
now have a totally
different way of studying
the economy because
they all use software
and big data in a
totally different way
than their predecessors did.
I think computer science and
software and information theory
is colonizing the
rest of science
the same way tech is colonizing
the rest of business.
I think biology is
actually front and center
and that would be a very
interesting area to go into
and then I think
economics is going
to be super interesting,
of which cryptocurrency
is one example but there will
be many intersection points.
Then, I think there's
probably another half dozen
after that are
equally interesting.
I'd be trying to bring computer
science in other fields
and then build
things that there's
been no way to even conceive.
We have a company we just
funded as an example using deep
learning to do cancer
biopsies via blood draws.
If you talk about the
long term implications
not only for diagnosis
of cancer but also,
turns out for
treatment of cancer
to actually have a
complete map of tumors
in the body with complete
analysis from a blood draw
is just light years ahead
in terms of the outcomes
that you could generate and
to us it's a software company.
It's a deep learning
and data company.
QUENTIN HARDY: Thank you cloud.
VINT CERF: There's
a couple of problems
here that we should
probably recognize.
Just knowing genetic
sequences is no longer enough.
We have to know all
about epigenetics,
we have to know about
the microbiome in our gut
because that's how our
systems have evolved together.
Our immune systems
are not just human,
they're also microbiome as well.
So that's one issue.
There's still a lot to
be done in this space.
QUENTIN HARDY: OK.
I want to say, by the
way, we just passed
the $2,000 mark and the--
VINT CERF: Been keeping track.
QUENTIN HARDY: We're
going to go to lightning
in just a second with
a bunch of questions
that we got off Twitter
before we had this session.
Very quickly though, I want
to take a quick break and then
why don't you tell them about
the invention no one knows
you two created.
VINT CERF: This is where I get
to blame him for everything.
Back in the day around 1994,
he's off with Jim Clark
doing Netscape communications
and I am at MCI,
and we decide we're going to
build the MCI mall, not mail,
I did that back in '83,
this is the mall in 1994.
MARC ANDREESSEN: It is
the Amazon, pre-Amazon.
VINT CERF: Pre-Amazon and
you know that well, yeah '94.
So, we decided, where is the
highest point of departure
for this and it's obviously
the Netscape Communications
server and clients.
So we bought $7,000,000 worth of
licenses for servers and yeah,
well, you're welcome.
MARC ANDREESSEN:
Thank you, thank you.
QUENTIN HARDY:
You're on your way.
VINT CERF: Then I
realized that there
are going to be
transactions on the servers.
And there are going to be broken
transactions because people
will just disconnect or get
halfway through and decide
not to do anything.
I'm sitting here
thinking, my servers
are going to be full of all
this cruft, broken transactions,
and I don't want all
that crap because I don't
know when to get rid of it.
So, I go over to Marc
and I say listen Marc,
I don't want all this crap.
Why don't you find a way to
store it on the client side
and let me get the state
of the transaction when
I need it, when they show up
and say, I'd like to finish.
So, he goes and invents cookies.
If you don't like
cookies, it's his fault
[LAUGHTER]
QUENTIN HARDY: There you go.
Put two great minds together
and you get cookies.
MARC ANDREESSEN: Strategically
though it gives them
a really fun name so that
nobody would ever get upset.
You may not know the other
side of the story so back--
VINT CERF: Oh, yeah.
Well, you want to
tell the other side?
MARC ANDREESSEN: I'm
not going to tell
the side you want
me to tell I'm going
to tell another side
that you don't know.
We get literally the
$7,000,000 check by the way MCI
our second customer.
The first customer is a little
bit more creative application.
I'll let you leave that
to your imagination.
MCI was the first mainstream
business customer.
We get the $7,000,000 check,
very big day for a start up
company to get a $7
million dollar check.
So as you get hurt at work
or working around the clock
or writing code six
months or whatever goes by
and we finally get all the
code done and I'm like OK,
thank god it's done, test
is ready to go OK, send it
out, get it over to
them, and that's great
and, I get to work
the next day and we
get the angriest
phone call I think
I've ever received because
we actually did not
have a process for
shipping software
and so the deployment
engineer burned
the software onto
a CD-ROM and put
the CD-ROM in a Ziploc
baggie and shipped it to MCI.
Literally, we paid
$7,000,000 and you sent us
a CD-ROM in a baggie.
QUENTIN HARDY: It
was a new baggie.
[INAUDIBLE]
MARC ANDREESSEN: It was
not his sandwich bag.
The good news is that
it was freshly fetched
from the kitchen.
VINT CERF: At least it
wasn't in a bag of Wheaties
like that other
AOL guy was doing.
MARC ANDREESSEN: Right.
Exactly, exactly, exactly.
QUENTIN HARDY: OK so, I want to
move to the challenge round off
of Twitter.
First off, if software is
eating the world and software
will live in the cloud, what
forms of software regulation
do you think will take place?
VINT CERF: I'm sorry, I
didn't hear the question.
QUENTIN HARDY: Software
regulation in the cloud.
VINT CERF: Oh oh OK.
This is not a popular
opinion to express.
I did it when I was the
president of the Association
for Competing Machinery.
For all you guys out there
that are writing software,
it probably all has
bugs at some point.
You're not going to get
away with it anymore.
You're going to have to take
responsibility for your bugs.
We need better tools to
avoid making mistakes that
turn into exploitable
bugs, but I
think that's going to be the
biggest challenge lying ahead.
Software is
surrounding everything.
Now it's in everything
and the mistakes
will become more and more
visible and potentially more
harmful and so, I
think that there
will be pressure for some
sort of regulatory oversight.
Maybe you'll have to
get a license in order
to do major projects like
a civil engineer has to do,
I don't know how that's
all going to evolve.
But I don't think
that we can get away
with anymore I used to make a
living writing software so I'm
very empathetic about this
but it's a serious issue now.
QUENTIN HARDY: OK.
Marc will cloud
and its suppliers
become totally
commoditized or is there
some value in the cloud
chain down the road?
MARC ANDREESSEN: There
is a theory at foot
and there are people on Wall
Street who certainly believe
the cloud by definition has
to be a commodity because it's
a bunch of servers in Iraq
and anybody can do it.
My experience was that,
I think from 2,000 when--
AWS launched in what, '05 from
'06 to I think '13 or maybe
'14, 2014, every industry expert
I spoke to who was associated
with any kind of systems vendor
box vendor, they swore up,
down, and sideways emphatically
angrily that it would be
impossible for the cloud
vendors to ever make any money.
Just flat impossible
because literally they're
just putting boxes in Iraq
and what can that be worth.
And specifically,
AWS there's no way
like AWS has to be bleeding
cash and then Amazon
was either forced or chose
to finally break out AWS
and it turns out, of course,
AWS is Amazon's most profitable
business.
QUENTIN HARDY: By
far the best margins.
MARC ANDREESSEN: And every
time you buy a book on Amazon,
it's being actually
cross subsidized by AWS
not the other way around.
That caused a, I would
say, rapid reevaluation
inside these
companies, most of whom
it's now too late to
react to what's happening.
I think existence proof
is that Amazon is plenty
profitable on AWS
and then, I just
think this whole conference
is an example of this,
I think cloud is
just getting started.
I think the layers
of functionality
that are going to
come in on top is
all the stuff we've
been talking about,
about AI and all these things.
These things are just going
to get more and more useful.
As they get more
and more useful,
they're going to
be able to command
higher and higher prices
for real value received
and fantastic margins.
I think they'll end up being
very high margin businesses
and with very happy customers.
QUENTIN HARDY: OK
VINT CERF: Marc has
just used a term which
I'd like to underscore the
layers in the architecture
because what we're
really involved with now
is the sciences
of the artificial.
We're creating an
artificial world
that we can manipulate and
change and experiment with
and that's just
going to continue
so that means more
opportunities for new businesses
QUENTIN HARDY: OK.
Two edge core questions.
Utility at core and
power at the edge.
How does that dynamic
play out you think?
And likewise, we talked
about death of cloud
you don't see that
coming at all.
But, are we moving towards
an increasingly powerful edge
or does the core become
a stronger and stronger
repository?
Do they kind of
chase each other,
the way they always have?
VINT CERF: The pendulum
swings back and forth.
We've seen it happen many times.
Now we're in the same place
where we were in the 1960s.
People would show pictures
of giant buildings
called the computing foundry
with smoke coming out
of the top and then everybody
went to the private machines
and departmental machines and
things like that and so it
keeps swinging back and forth.
When you start thinking about
the very low power things
that we use for mobiles and
other related IOT devices,
those may end up in the
computing environment
of the computing centers as
well simply because they are not
power hungry.
I don't think the clouds
are going to go away at all
I think what will
happen is the edge
is going to keep getting more
and more and proliferated
but the clouds are going to
have to be there in order
to make things more coherent
QUENTIN HARDY: OK.
What kind of
structures do you think
could become fundamental
technologies, like DNS did?
VINT CERF: I'm sorry say--
QUENTIN HARDY: What kind
of fundamental structures
do you think might become
important in the future?
VINT CERF: Probably the
most fundamental one
has to do with the semantic
modeling of what's going on.
The thing which
makes AI powerful
is its ability to build
models that are analytic.
Right now we don't
do that very well.
We have neural networks whose
function we don't understand.
If there were a powerful
addition to the computing
environment that
we could point out,
it would be the
ability to extract
a model of the real
world. for example,
or a model of an artificial
world like a company
and then try to understand
how to reason about it.
We don't have a vocabulary for
that yet, let alone grammar,
so, if there is a
breakthrough somewhere,
that's the one that I
think would find the most
interesting.
QUENTIN HARDY: OK.
Last question for
the both of you.
Biggest regrets and proudest
moments in your career?
VINT CERF: I'm sorry, the--
QUENTIN HARDY: Biggest regrets
and proudest moments in your--
VINT CERF: Wow.
I wish that I had used
IPv6 instead of IPv4
to begin with because--
QUENTIN HARDY: I meant
to bring that up.
VINT CERF: Who knew.
And we probably could
have done a better
job of using public key crypto
except that the timing wasn't
very good.
The paper that was
published in '76
didn't include an algorithm.
Then RSA comes along
a little bit later
just as we freeze
the internet design
and I want to get it
implemented so we can figure out
if it'll work, and so I put
off the public key stuff
for a while.
If it had been at
the right time,
we would have included
it except for one thing,
the internet was built
by graduate students
and you were all one of
those once upon a time.
They're the most undisciplined
people in the world
and getting them to
use crypto properly
would have been
impossible anyway.
It's too bad but that's an
alternate history I think.
MARC ANDREESSEN: No regrets.
QUENTIN HARDY:
You're shocked right?
MARC ANDREESSEN: I'm from
the Luke Hayes school,
always forward and
never backwards.
Proudest accomplishment
I got to say,
the people I've been
able to work with
and certainly Vint
is one of these
but just the people I've
been able to work with.
Especially now, younger
people coming up
in the industry and
the ability for people
to be able to realize their
dreams and create new things
and be able to learn.
I think we're all in the
process of learning and growing
all the time.
And I think our ability
to help each other
and teach each other in the
end, is the most important thing
and the most rewarding.
QUENTIN HARDY: That's a
really great note to end on.
I had some more questions
but we've run out of time.
This was fascinating, high value
and we ended up over $3,000 so,
thank you so much.
MARC ANDREESSEN: Thank you.
Thank you, Quentin.